I never thought of myself as one of the
first wave of women,
much of my career.
I thought that I've sort of been
following and the women who went ahead
of me in blazing the trails that made it
possible to do what I've done.
And this really is the first point in my
life where I've gotten to be the first
woman.
I think a lot of the reason it happened
has a lot to do with Kellogg is um,
has a lot to do also with the state of
where business education has gotten to
right now.
Women students come up to me and women
from many different areas come up and
say,
how did you get to be dean of Kellogg?
And I said,
well,
don't follow my model was the wrong
button.
Right?
You know,
hey,
I was a woman.
Be I was a social psychologist rather
than an economist.
And See,
I just spent six years in undergraduate
business education.
And none of those have tended to be the
power alleys.
And yet,
what I think it tells us the fact that
Kellogg was ready to apply in a woman
and a top business school was,
is that the world has changed a lot.
There's a much deeper appreciation of
psychology in business school
environments in addition to economics.
You know,
that's something I knew was important
when I made the choice to study
psychology years ago.
Um,
but I think the world has certainly
embraced that view more so.
It's an interesting thing that when you
look at graduate schools of business,
about 30 percent to 35 percent of the
students tend to be women.
And this is true.
What else?
You know,
it all top business schools through
every sort of sector of the business
school education domain.
Whereas if you look at law schools,
medical schools,
they tend to be about 50 percent women
and the feeder undergraduate programs at
colleges and research universities are
now,
most of them are at least 50 percent
women,
if not more.
This persistent fact that business
schools are lower is an interesting
question and people are just beginning
to get some data around it.
I recently read a study done by the
Simmons College and School of business
and it's finding there are negative
attitudes towards business of women in
the high school and the junior high
school years and they think that that
may be in part explaining why not as
many women are going to graduate schools
of business.
I still think it's a perplexing question
though,
because businesses such a dominant
institution in our society and so many
people are drawn to it.
It's the most popular undergraduate
major in the country.
So while I see the negative business
attitudes piece,
you know,
I keep wondering is that the whole
answer?
It's important data.
It's the cheapest degree.
It's only two years,
redmond,
three,
four or five.
So it truly is a perplexing question.
Part of it I wonder is if we haven't
misrepresented in some ways what you
learn at business school.
To me the greatest skill that you learn
is how to build effective organizations.
You learn about the markets and how they
work,
but you learn how to build effective
organizations,
which is how we as human beings
organize,
which is how we get things done.
And I think of we did a better job at
explaining to people that that's what
it's about.
I think that more women might be drawn
to it because women naturally organize
in their communities and our families,
uh,
in our churches and you know,
in all sorts of.
And I can't help wondering if we need to
get more enlightened language so people
truly understand that business school
really is about building effective
organizations within a market context.
But it can also be in a not for profit
context or a religious context.
I think it's just a question of time,
quite honestly,
in terms of the unique challenges to
women.
We've broken the glass ceilings now in
many places,
not maybe it is high numbers as some
people would have hoped,
but we've done it.
You know,
it's interesting that we broke the glass
ceiling of Harvard before we did have a
major business school,
for example.
Right.
We've broken the glass ceilings that a
lot of fortune 500 companies.
I recently had the privilege of being
asked to go to the fortune most powerful
women summit.
It was in Washington dc this past fall.
And the room was just packed with these
incredibly talented women and I looked
around and I found myself intimidated
and I realize people are intimidated by
what I've done.
I mean,
I think that we're doing it.
It's a question of choices for women
because it does require trade offs.
You don't get to have it all.
You can't have a perfect marriage,
perfect kids the perfect job and be in
perfect shape physically and I think
it's a question of tradeoffs and how far
women decided to go in the into business
I think will impart,
determined,
be determined by choices about child
rearing and the structure of the
American family and how do we decide to
allocate our resources.
Economics is the study of markets and
we'll.
Sociology also involves the study of
markets.
Many disciplines take an eye on them.
It's important to remember that all the
market is is a group of like
transactions and all the transaction is
as a buyer and seller getting together a
buyer saying,
I want that a seller saying,
I don't want it as much as you want it
because the price you're willing to give
me is higher than the price that I,
that I you know that I that I need to
keep it and that's the nature of human
commerce going all the way back to the
earliest days of human organizing and
understanding that all a market is an
aggregation of people selling and buying
similar things and that our models of
markets are just that they're models.
Supply and demand don't exist.
There.
A model of what we see in everyday life
that help us understand everyday life.
When we add you're great.
All those buyer and seller transactions
together and helping students understand
how human society functions,
how it naturally self organizes,
which is what a market is,
is what a free market economy is.
Because even in the socialist economies
and the communists,
those markets existed.
They made my,
maybe weren't tracked officially,
but they were there and they were
operating.
And so when I think about how we bring
that into education,
it's how do we help students understand
how humans organize,
how,
who humans interact and bring value to
each other.
I Love Adam Smith calls it about our
propensity to truck.
Now obviously I never thought of that as
a verb.
Um,
and,
and had meaning back then,
but I love that phrase now.
Our propensity to truck is what makes us
different from the,
the animals,
our propensity to engage in transactions
of me to sell you something and you to
buy it so that I don't,
you know,
you'll do the farming and I'll do the
sewing.
And by having this propensity to truck
will each have more wellbeing in our
lives.
It's a very simple principle and I
sometimes think that when we use words
like markets and networks,
things we create an abstraction of
reality.
These are models of how we exist
because I look out at the world and I
see what creates wealth and business by
the way for me is organizations and
markets which are both important parts
of it and it's organization's operating,
eating as actors in markets.
Um,
and I look out at the world and I
watched.
It's not the government that's creating
jobs.
It's not the governance that's creating
innovation.
It's not the church that's doing it.
It's not,
you know,
you can get something done so much
faster with a for profit business than
you can with a not for profit or a
government or a religious based business
or even an NGO and you can move jobs and
move wealth and solve problems so much
faster.
It's pretty obvious.
It's the dominant social institution.
Now,
do I like that every day?
No,
because sometimes as it's become the
dominant social institution,
we've allowed market based logics to
dominate our thinking.
I'm part of how did 2008 occurred?
How did it all your classmates get?
Lord,
as you talked about to Wall Street is
because money has become even more
motivating to us in the age of the
business as the dominant social
institution and money is only a metric.
Money is only one place of value in life
and if there's a sort of a challenge
that we're going to have,
if we're going to recalibrate,
it's going to be as a human on a psyche
level,
understanding how much business has come
to dominate and homogenized and control
culture in some cases and making
conscious decisions about where we're
going to let that happen and where we're
not.
Um,
right now we're dealing with the
unintended consequences of business
emerging as the dominant social
institution and we're beginning to have
dialogues about how do we push that
monetary metric back a little to let
other values on the table.
As a society,
both nationally and globally,
markets aren't fair or unfair.
Markets create wealth and they're
incredibly efficient at allocating goods
and resources and creating surplus for
society.
That makes people better off,
but markets have nothing to do with how
that wellbeing gets allocated across
members of society.
And you can't argue they're fair or
unfair,
they're agnostic there,
a moral,
not immoral,
amoral.
It's we as human beings who get to
decide how much each person should be
entitled to on a moral and values based
level.
And I personally am somebody who
believes the I,
the fact that a billion out of the 6
billion of us on the planet live on
what?
Less than a dollar a day isn't fair.
And I don't believe that markets can
solve it.
I do believe they can create more wealth
to spread,
to help solve it.
But if we just allow markets unchecked
and somehow argued that will take care
of it.
I've seen no data to indicate that
markets will know because they aren't
knowing.
They're allocating their generative,
not loving.
Clearly the service sector is where we
excel on the US economy versus the
manufacturing.
Uh,
and so clearly that's going to be and
the knowledge based sectors because
that's where we have still have a leg up
in the world in higher education and
people who come out with critical
thinking skills.
So clearly those pieces are going to
lead.
Finance is already playing a bigger role
than any of us thought it would,
but I personally,
in terms of sort of hopes and dreams,
I think that social enterprise is having
more on a small scale,
but there's more vigor in that than I
would have guessed five or 10 years ago
and that excites me
for the foreseeable future.
The service sector has eclipsed
manufacturing and a lot of it's a simple
cost argument.
We cannot manufacturer as economically
in the United States as you can in
developing countries because all kinds
of tax reasons,
benefit reasons and things that we
require and are good for society.
The interesting thing about economics
and markets and the developing the
developed world as we've never played
out this game before at a global scale.
We don't know if there is long term harm
to losing a manufacturing base.
Intuitively it feels very uncomfortable.
It's unclear where certain sectors of
our society are going to continue to
find employment.
When you drive through Detroit,
it's absolutely scary in some situations
are cities like buffalo that used to
have these manufacturing basis,
so I would argue we don't know the
answer to that,
but I'm not sure we can fix it right now
until people are willing to not look for
the lowest cost on certain manufactured
goods.
The developed world will win out or the
developing world as a job space for
manufacturing will win out over the
developed world and in order for that to
change,
we'd have to change how we buy and how
we consume and it's hard to foresee in
the near future how that's going to
change.
So in many ways I don't know that we
have a choice.
We have to play it out and see what
happens.
The beautiful thing is the Internet.
For example,
we didn't even know about it 20 years
ago,
even 15,
nobody thought it was going to circle
the globe as fast as it did.
There's so many,
you know,
and that's where you get your hope and
sense of surprise is there may well be
things that are going to happen that we
can't even imagine that make this
service dominated,
developed economy,
just fondling.
And what we have to do when I get back
to education is keep educating the
thinkers and the innovators and the
critiquers who will help those
breakthroughs come to bear because
that's the only hope for human society.
Because at some point the developing
world will have played out this chain as
well.
Um,
and we'll,
we'll have robots manufacturing
everything basic.
And the question is,
what is human life?
Then?
What is the marketplace?
How do we find meaning and value and get
our needs met and feed our families.